this video is sponsored by Shadow verse
yes shadow versus back to sponsor us and
if you missed it last time it's a free
to play anime card game for PC and
Mobile since their last sponsorship I
legitimately got hooked for a little
while and have been playing in my free
time well the campaign at least because
I tried going online [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
dammit are for [ __ ] and I preferred the
campaign for some reason if your knee
can actually get 50 free card packs from
the get-go and then form your strategy
around different leader classes to suit
your playstyle
right now they are even doing one punch
man collaboration where you can get
sites on my Guinness and touch samake
skins click the link below to download
it on Steam or you can also find it on
ios and android the one punch man
collaboration ends on a 20th of june
though so get them while you can
which leads nicely to what we're talking
about today
hey guys hero association here back at
it again making a 100% accurate tier
list and first we got my boy guinness
he's new but he's a robot
he's opiate buck s tier and now we got
this guy i I don't know what he's done
probably nothing
see Tier one punch man season one was a
game changer for me not just as a series
but as a fan who watches and appreciates
the medium of anime back when it aired
in 2013 there wasn't really much of a
focus on anime production sure people
news studios but there were kind of a
black box you'd insert money into and
out pops an anime then one punch man
exploded onto the scene each episode was
[ __ ] with god-like animation in a
consistent dosage we hardly ever got to
see for a weekly TV series and with the
sensational hit that it was more and
more information came out there wasn't
because of an enormous budget it was
able to achieve this but because of the
talent behind the staff members who
worked on it
Shingo Natsume and his team at madhouse
left their mark not only was it a
worldwide phenomenon but it forever
reframed the way a lot of us would
approach high-quality animation so it's
not much of a surprise that much of the
discussion around season 2 has been
around is production and animation from
a change in studio to new staff members
to rumors of a hellish production cycle
whatever the reason is plain to see that
the final result has been a wildly
inconsistent animation quality like an
one second be like and the next can be
like I don't think anyone can argue that
the animation has been a step down
whether it's bad is up for debate
there's already been so much discussion
around that even though it's not the
only thing I've noticed that's different
from last season so instead I wanted to
shine some light on vats in how one
punch man's story is developing and the
monster association saga itself see as
someone who's gone on to read the manga
and then the web comics there's a lot I
actually prefer from the source material
season 2 is adapting from over what
season 1 adapted because aside from the
incredible fight scenes one of the huge
appeal of one punch man was how well a
parody the superhero genre and shown in
battle tropes and at the point where it
ended it felt like the right place there
was adequate time to explore all the
ideas that really needed to be explored
it hadn't overplayed its joke to the
point of stillness and Saitama had found
a villain who he didn't defeat in one
punch in an epic showdown that raised
the stakes higher than anything that
came before it so where can we really go
from there anyone who's been following
season 2
has read ahead in the manga will surely
notice one thing we increasingly see
less of in one punch man the one punch
man okay Sytsma has gotten considerably
less screen time and it reflects a
structural shift as a series addresses
the impending problem of gimmick or not
yes fights will get boring if they all
end in one punch
Saitama serves as both the series as
bigger strength and problem see how much
lonely he interacts with the sleep
serious world of hero serves as a lot of
the basis to the comedy where there's
only so many different ways you can play
it and I think the original series did a
great job at finding vastly different
scenarios to keep it fresh but
eventually the novelty was going to wear
off and it's here in season 2 that the
series switches up its
monster-of-the-week format where every
op builds up another big baddie
foresight Amata comically takedown to
essentially one big story arc and site
owners had hardly anything to do well he
is participating in a tournament ugh but
I mean it's less of her jaw and more of
a tournament talk yay the season we see
this series slipped into something that
can be recognized as the more span
formats because even though a lot of
these elements started off as a simple
parody one punch man's cast and world is
the genuinely interesting conglomerates
that can stand on its own and deserves
to be explored and that's kind of what
happens we see a lot more focus put on
the side characters more detail is added
to the world building as it shifts more
of a straight forward actually show with
satirical elements in it I think of
their somewhat similar to what Shaun of
the Dead or zombie landed with the
zombie genre sure they took popular
tropes and satirized them but really
they are just standard zombie movies
where the characters we are following
happen to be really funny there are so
many moving parts ranged from the
unequivocally badass the completely
absurd you've got the various powers and
relationships of yes Class Heroes the
world of ninjas samurais martial artists
mechanical beings and then there's
someone like king who is basically the
antithesis to Saitama a totally
powerless dude who somehow guests by
through the intimidation of a Superman
reputation he got by complete accident
which I thought was actually a genius
move and remains one of the funniest
elements I consistently laughed at in
the manga also not forgetting the best
sister duo you can ask for between
Fubuki and her old
sister the 28 year old cinder a tornado
tatsumaki I believe people like to refer
to her as the legal lolly for legal
reasons we're just gonna be using the
term petite milf now this may not sound
very different outside characters were
handled in season one but this gets me
to by far the best thing about the
monster association saga which is gara
gara is one punch man's take it
introducing an antihero you empathize
with here is someone who's a villain not
because he's inherently evil but because
he hates heroes he's someone who's
always identified more with the underdog
with monsters typically being the
unpopular underdogs that are there to be
defeated by the heroes so he chooses to
be that victorious monster himself
despite still having his own set of
moral codes and by god he actually turns
into the closest thing this world has to
a typical main character he's not a
monster that starts off as a strongest
but he's someone who gets see grow and
develop with each battle who takes part
in he gets pushed to the edge teaches on
the verge of death and somehow finds a
way to surpass his limits every time and
as the series progresses he gets by far
the most development out of any
character it's unfortunate of the season
we won't get to fully see where his
character ends up because he
encapsulated will I find to be the
biggest strength of this series in the
new saga one punch man has always done
well in building up anticipation even
though there was absolutely no tension
that Saitama would come out victorious
it still managed to build up these
monsters to a point where you'd really
anticipate what would happen when they
meet Saitama then you'd feel stupid for
being like oh yeah it's still one punch
man I don't I don't know why I was
expecting anything else but now what's
interesting isn't how comically he'll
dispatch these new big baddies but
instead it's how all these different
characters that are being built up will
react to him as a plot element so item
as role becomes that of the nuclear
option and seeing how these characters
change and sometimes find their
resolution to that character arcs isn't
something that was so focused on before
I would love to talk about how well I
thought garras character was handled all
the way through to the [ __ ] web
comics and his resolution with Saitama
but that's a far off spoiler and I don't
want to be bad guy so instead let's take
the entire tournament arc as an example
because this support is really about
Sudi
so to use the genius martial artist who
has never had to work hard in a day of
his life he is incredibly lazy and
carefree but phenomenally strong
fish vain incredibly arrogance just
having one of those smug faces people
would definitely submit to our slash
punchable faces spoiler alert
not really giving much respect to anyone
because he's never met anyone stronger
than him and like a certain someone he's
bored of course he gets easily defeated
by Sytsma but that's not really the
turning point for him because after that
is when the monsters invade and he puts
up a fight for the first time he gets
beaten bloody the unparalleled
confidence he once had is completely
destroyed and he finds himself in
despair begging for his life coming to
the realization that even someone as
almighty as him needs a hero to save him
so of course who shows up just in time
no no more she yeah they do monitor just
kill your boo Claire she does this see
here this moment to me in the manga was
way more emotionally gratifying than
anything the serious attack would
previously and after he sees saitama's
overwhelming strength he changes his
attitude and finds a newfound respect
for Heroes it's the resolution of his
character arc that is so satisfying so
much so that we don't even get to see
Saitama defeat the big monster he gets
taken out completely your screen which
I've seen many people say was
anticlimactic and I'm just here thinking
have you not been watching the same show
it's almost always been anticlimactic
where the focus here was never about
sight somewhere kicking butt it will sue
to you this kind of sums up the role
Saitama plays now he's more of a side
character in his own show someone who's
there to reset the stakes and honestly
I'm all for it because he serves as just
another interesting element that fits
into this world and since he's been used
more sparingly I found that when he does
do something it's much harder hitting
pun intended then unfortunately is where
the compliments ends because all this
doesn't detract from the fact that as a
fan of the franchise while still okay
season 2 just hasn't hits nearly the
same marks as the material was adapting
from maybe it's the direction maybe it's
the animation but I can't quite put into
words how an anime could give
technically a faithful adaptation of the
source material presented in the way
that they are just animating the panels
and just not leave nearly the same
impact in any aspect as much credit as I
give to whiny for managing to craft the
story that thousands can love in spite
of his amateur art Murata
managed to elevate it into another level
and the original team managed to use
that and push the vision even further
beyond and I don't think it would have
been the wild wife's inflation it is had
it look like what season two is giving
us as gratifying as it was seeing
moments like this Sudi used batter words
Sytsma and the monger was an absolute
spectacle that's I can only imagine how
amazing it would look if it was animated
by the original team the source material
is still fantastic which is why even
though I'm still enjoying it season two
just feels like a bit of a
disappointment the perception isn't
towards how good the show actually is
it's to how good the show could have
been it's never a nice beginning to feel
like you've gone through a downgrade
just so it's gone from this legendary
production using with passion and love
to just a bog-standard manga adaptation
in stark contrast to its Little Brother
mob psycho 100 and the other title of
this generation attack on titan being
the best they've ever been one punch man
season 2 wasn't the sensational return
we all wanted it to be but it's still a
half-decent show all things said and
done
does this title need godly animation to
be enjoyable absolutely not and there is
some irony to be found that there's been
so much debate about the aesthetics of a
show that found its roots in a webcomic
that looks like scribbles on a napkin
but even so I find it's hard
recommending this season over the manga
and that's more of a compliment to
Murata's art instead having reread it
for comparison's sake I've grown indeed
found appreciation just how much more
genius maratha is for being able to put
action onto paper not even including his
chapters that are essentially just
animated he frames his panels flow so
seamlessly that I got a better sense of
speed and impact than I did actually
looking at it animated here and with
just how much action there is not only
this season but also past it I cannot
recommend it more because what's always
struck me about one punch man more than
the series itself is the route that it
came from reading up about the original
author 1 and how manga was his passion
in school but he was too embarrassed to
tell anyone
so he'd upload illustrations online
using his mobile phone camera of all
things which eventually led into one
punch man he only intended it to be a
one-shot idea but he would not only find
an unexpected number of people who loved
his work and urged him on to continue
but would also by complete chance get
noticed by Yusuke Murata
who would want to help him remake it
this would then be adapted into an anime
by Shingo Natsume knees team who deliver
a production of legendary status
brimming with artistic visions not
because they had a big budget but
because you could feel the passion
burning through every single cut of this
show like his own protagonists one was
just a manga author for fun and I think
that pure innocent passion had carried
on through every iteration of his series
not to say there isn't passion behind
that people working on season 2 I know
that definitely is but it certainly
seems like it's been marred by a hellish
production cycle that has hindered what
the people working on it could have
achieved and it just feels like anything
less than the best for this series is
just a bit of a missed opportunity
first time hey guys hope you enjoyed the
video I achieved up what's my tripod
somewhere so I'm going for handheld
today thank you very much to shout at us
answering me again today if any of what
size shows that sub interests smooth and
click the link in the description to
give it a try and with that said thank
you very much - jazz Dion PDD in your
life while side slope it pronounced me
at wrong waterside supreme sayin
Nicholas Tatum sisters one zero zero
eight six and the pool and everyone else
might pay job helping to support me this
one just another update I do plans to do
another stream of the summer anime
seasonal chart at the end of this month
it should be in the last week of the
month I haven't given it a concrete date
yet but I'm hoping that it's gonna be on
the weekend no guarantees if I'm not
able to announce the dates officially in
another video before them then keep an
eye out to my Twitter but I'll be
streaming it on youtube so if you have
the bail notification you should get a
notification when I do a stream I think
that's the first every time I actually
ask people to click on the bail know
station anyway those that's it for me I
think you got and I'll see you all